Welcome back everyone this is going to be my brand
new green lantern hbo announcement you probably
just saw they finally started dropping all this
news about what's going on with the green lantern
series so we'll break it all down we even got some
footage of the deleted scene of john stewart green
lantern that was supposed to be in zack snyder's
justice league snyder cut so i'll also talk about
that during the video too you've probably been
seeing a whole bunch of green lantern stuff being
posted in your timeline including ryan reynolds
posting more green lantern stuff which i'll talk
about but if you're new to the channel be sure
to subscribe to get all the videos i will do
episode videos for the green lantern hbo
series when it does premiere next year
but the really big stuff you probably saw the
news this past week they finally announced
finn wittrock as guy gardner in the green
lantern hbo series that they're getting
ready to shoot right now that's why they made the
casting announcement ryan reynolds even offered
his own endorsement joking that it was all part
of his plan it's all falling into place i know
there are all kinds of questions about whether
or not he'll be involved with the franchise ever
again in any capacity recently you probably
saw the video that he posted he posted this
funny video of himself re-watching his green
lantern movie for the first time in forever
i think he said he'd never actually watched
the theatrical cut after the premiere and here
this is has been our home for countless millennia
it was created for us by the guardians if you look
real closely there you can see he's even wearing
his original green lantern ring from the movie
that he kept that's the actual ring that he
wore during the film also funny detail about
that movie too is that because taika watiti's an
actor he appeared during that film now obviously
both of them are big in the marvel universe
green lantern yeah yeah green lantern
what pilot he wore a uniform
i think he was a soldier
give me this i don't think so that maybe you're
thinking of um seth rogen green hornet that's it
yeah that's where you're getting completely
amazing in that but neither of us are seth
rogen i did no you did green lantern
there was definitely green line right
but in the big green lantern announcement they
named guy gardner as the lead of the show but
i believe the idea is that it's supposed to be
more of an ensemble series with the other green
lanterns that they're doing doing it is more of
a green lantern core series instead of a green
lantern series that just built around one of them
if you're not super familiar with the actor you
might remember him from american horror story or
other recent tv series but i'm excited to see what
he does with his version of guy gardner who's
basically known as the version of green lantern
just super hardcore personality compared to
people like hal jordan jon stewart and the
other earth-based green lanterns we know a lot
more about what's going on with the plot the
characters that they're doing and how this is
weaving in with the other big dc projects going
forward because they are still planning on doing
a green lantern core movie that i'll reference
during the video but the biggest stuff first
the green lanterns that they're doing include
sinestro guy gardner obviously as i just mentioned
alan scott jessica cruz simon baz kilwog and then
a couple of original characters that they're
just introducing for the purposes of the show
i know everyone's asking about diggle green
lantern from the arrowverse also talk about him
during the video as well because they still have
to wrap up that storyline the biggest thing though
obviously everyone noticed in this announcement
is in the roster of green lanterns they're doing
for season one is there's no mention of how jordan
or jon stewart which seems weird that they would
do so many of the bigger green lantern characters
but not the two biggest characters so it doesn't
mean that they won't appear on the show it just
sounds like they won't be main characters during
season one but obviously you can't do these other
green lanterns without hal jordan existing without
jon stewart existing so they do exist within the
universe the main reason why they're not starting
with them on the show is probably because they're
just saving them for the green lantern corps movie
that is still happening no release date on that
yet probably gonna be at least another two or
three years before we potentially see one also
part of the reason for them not doing jon stewart
on the show in particular probably has something
to do with what happened with the green lantern
during the justice league snyder cut i know a lot
of you were expecting to see green lantern court
during the justice league snyder cut and zack
snyder had been hyping them up for a long time
teasing that there would be green lantern stuff
happening during the film and we did see versions
of green lanterns like we did see the dead kill
log inside that nightmare flash forward sequence
the potential future timelines that the mother
box shows cyborg so during the movie when they
show you this dead kill walk scene like superman
is basically floating over the remains of the
justice league in the hall of justice as if he's
killed all them like he's holding batman's cow
that was just meant to be one of the possible
futures as referenced by the kryptonian ship
like you hear the voice of the ship telling them
not to proceed with their course of action because
it will lead to something very terrible because
it's also extrapolating all these potential future
nightmare outcomes but originally what the plan
was is that zack snyder was going to introduce
the dceu version of green lantern that would have
then gone on to the green lantern corps movie the
same way that he introduced the wonder woman
character in batman v superman then she went
on to the first wonder woman film and then came
back and crossed over again same thing with ezra
miller's version of the flash same thing with
cyborg all the other characters when he wound
up leaving the project though things went into
turn around and they completely changed their plan
for the future of dc movies this was all years
ago but apparently they still always planned
doing a green lantern corps movie at some point
i've already done a video about the plot of the
justice league sequels so i'll post a link for
that in the description but the whole idea is the
green lantern corps become much bigger characters
during justice league 2 and justice league 3.
and eventually you do see them come in like the
cavalry during justice league 3 when they finally
defeat darkseid it felt very much like the thanos
battle at the end of avengers end game where you
have all these many avengers assembling to fight
thanos's army but then the idea was the green
lanterns that zack snyder was going to introduce
would go on to their own space based movies
and crossovers the same way that you have the
guardians of the galaxy in the marvel universe so
the deal this past week though with zack snyder's
version of green lantern and the justice league
snyder cut is he actually filmed the green lantern
scene when he showed the studio the final version
of the snyder cut they made him take out the
green lanterns they're like you have to get rid
of this or else we're not going to release this
movie so he wound up replacing his green lantern
scene at the end of the film the end credit scene
with the martian manhunter scene which obviously
is still very cool but it would have been very
cool to actually see a version of green lantern
there was another idea i had for the green lantern
that wasn't ryan and so i thought that if we had
gone down this path of green lantern i would
have had to have ryan as the additional lantern
got it so it could have been maybe he would
have been there as well as other lanterns
as well as another lantern that would have been
but that's another story now because the actor
has been posting his scenes and zack snyder's
been talking about it we actually have a look
at what that would have been so like i said it
would have been jon stewart and kilwog showing
up to batman's lake house to warn him about what's
happening with darkseid the actor's name is wayne
carr but the whole thing with him being the
jon stewart of the justice league snyder cut is
that zack snyder added him during the additional
photography like he literally shot these scenes
in his backyard remember the nightmare scene with
batman and everyone in the future that's a brand
new scene with the joker he shot that literally
in his backyard with a bunch of green screens
so i think the idea is that originally if he would
have never left the project if things would have
gone according to plan it would have obviously
been a different actor i don't know if it would
have always been jon stewart or if it would
have been hal jordan in the original version
so because the studio made him get rid of this
green lantern scene in the snyder cut i'm assuming
that this wayne car actor will not be playing jon
stewart or version of him in any future dc movies
but a little while ago they actually just
cancelled their new gods movie because it
was basically going to be a dark side film and
they said part of the reason was is they didn't
want to do a second version of darkseid so soon
after seeing a version of him in the snyder cut
so the theory is they didn't want zack snyder
doing a version of green lantern jon stewart
in his film because they have plans to do jon
stewart in something else coming up pretty soon
but for the green lantern corps hbo series they
didn't say exactly how they're going to handle
the timeline because alan scott is also meant to
be a really big character and he's the golden age
green lantern so he'd either have to be really old
in present day or they have to change some of the
continuity a little bit and it doesn't sound like
they're going to do that like they'll have some
way of referencing that he is one of the original
green lanterns on earth although technically
jalan gur from the justice league snyder cut is
the original green lantern of this sector of space
obviously he's not from earth he's an alien but
when he's killed by dark side here the really
cool connection to alan scott is that his body
basically became part of the star heart this
weapon that the green lantern corps was making
the star heart itself became alan scott's green
lantern battery and told him how to fashion his
own green lantern ring and even though sinestro is
probably gonna wind up becoming the main villain
because we're talking about season one and this
natural progression of the characters i think the
version of sinestro that we see during season one
won't be full-blown villain he'll probably still
be a green lantern corps version of the character
before he becomes a yellow lantern but i would
love if they can actually work themselves up
to the sinestro core i think the idea is that the
show could run five to seven seasons they would do
all that storyline it just feels like the natural
progression of those characters in that universe
james gunn is doing a suicide squad hbo series
spin-off from the movie and matt reeves is doing
a batman hbo series spin-off from his batman movie
both of them will involve characters that show up
during the films coming to the tv shows it's
just like marvel's disney plus series like the
loki series is getting ready to do episodes tom
hiddleston is the main character as a different
version of loki many different versions of loki
so i think the same thing is going to be true with
this green lantern series even though they don't
talk about how jordan or jon stewart during season
one will eventually see some of these green
lantern people show up during whatever future
green lantern core movie they wind up doing they
did tie the movies to the tv shows or at least the
arrowverse with that ezra miller and grant gustin
crossover scene so technically all the arrowverse
stuff is canon so a lot of you are like does that
mean the diggle is going to show up during the
green lantern hbo series i think we eventually see
more diggle green lantern stuff we'll see them pay
that off on the superman tv show or the current
aeroverse tv shows whenever they get to their next
big crossover everyone just let me know in the
comments which other characters and storylines
do you want them to do during the green lantern
hbo series it sounds like that's going to premiere
sometime after the peacemaker series maybe like
spring next year i've got a whole bunch of dc and
marvel videos that i'm working on i'll try to post
those as soon as possible everyone click here for
that brand new marvel loki trailer video and click
here for my falcon and winter soldier finale post
credit scene video thank you so much for watching
everyone stay safe and i'll see you guys tonight!